good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
Monday morning Lord and immoral the
Prime Minister Under Fire this morning
over his plans to tackle Small Boat
Crossings we'll get reaction from the
government today speaking to the Science
and Technology secretary Michelle Donald
of course Labor's Shadow Health
secretary West streeting plus the CEO of
safe passage UK it's Monday the 6th of
March
please searching for five young people
reported missing after a night out in
Cardiff have found three bodies
as the government sets out its latest
plan to tackle cross-channel migration
Charities say it will demonize refugees
but a people Smuggler tells us that the
wave of migrants will just carry on
coming
Boris Johnson reportedly puts his father
forward for a Knighthood as part of his
resignation honors list
anyone who am I in jail for
Charles Bronson Britain's most notorious
prisoner set to launch his bid for
Freedom today after nearly 50 years in
prison
deep freeze the UK could experience its
coldest day of the year this week as
Arctic air moves over the country we'll
tell you where the coldest weather will
be
wooded Glens and children firing flaming
arrows into funeral pies we meet the
pioneering Undertaker who's trying to
move away from Victorian value funerals
United apart here
here
seventh heaven for Liverpool after a
record rushing of their Rivals
Manchester United not everybody happy
about that as you can see
foreign
let's start with some breaking news from
the last couple of hours police
searching for five people reported
missing after a night out in Cardiff
have found three bodies let's get more
on that should be Rachel standing by for
us this morning Rachel what's happened
goodness well this is a tragic and
really shocking end to what started as a
missing person's inquiry a hunt for five
young people who went on a night out in
South Wales on Friday evening well last
heard from it about two o'clock on
Saturday morning and never came home
we've just heard in the past few hours
from gwent police that a car has been
recovered off the side of the a48 near
Saint melons in Cardiff in the car they
found three bodies and two people who
were it seems miraculously still alive
but they are seriously injured and
they've been rushed to hospital now we
understand the five people in this car
are the five youngsters who went missing
they're three women early all in their
early twenties who won a night out
they're from ports call they were in
Newports on Friday night they were last
seen leaving a bar there at around 11 15
with two men who were in their mid-20s
or early 30s it seems they travel
together in a Volkswagen Tiguan and they
were last heard from as I mentioned
already at about two o'clock in the
morning obviously on Saturday as the day
went on their family started to realize
they hadn't made it home and an urgent
missing person's inquiry was launched
through the weekend people getting more
and more concerned for them and now this
really shocking discovery of the car
which as I say seems to have been
involved in some sort of accident on
this very busy dual carriageway come off
the road on the a48 and has now been
recovered some 48 hours after the group
were last heard from now the police say
that the iopc have been informed the
families are being supported and at the
moment as you'd understand the road is
closed in both directions well they try
and work out what's happening I know
you're going to update us further aren't
you finite thanks very much indeed two
of them in a critical condition we'll
get more on that and we will update you
for the meantime the government's new
plan to clamp down on channel migrant
Crossings have been condemned this
morning as immoral about on people who
come to the UK illegally from claiming
Asylum is believed to be among the
proposals here we go let's have a look
at it in more detail more than 45
000 people crossed the channel in small
boats last year that's 60 percent higher
than in 2021 and another 3 000 migrants
have made the crossing so far this year
are your correspondent Adam Parsons is
in Dunkirk for us this morning hello to
you um Adam I know that you've been
speaking to these people Smugglers
haven't you over the last couple of days
yeah that's right and and that isn't a
huge and for a long time missing part of
this story okay is that we've spent
years talking about cross-channel
migration and the aspiring numbers we've
often heard from from police and from
charity workers here in northern France
dealing with migrants and of course from
politicians I've always I think used
that expression of of Smashing the
business model of people smuggling the
people that we've never heard from
before in this story are the people
Smugglers themselves and for very good
reason is that they tend to operate in
the shadows it is extremely hard to
strike up any form of relationship to
try and understand the role that they're
playing until now for the first time
ever we have sat down and held an
interview with one of these people
Smugglers to try to get an insight into
what motivates them into how they elude
Justice uh in terms of do they see
themselves as criminals and also to us
that question what would stop them what
would thwart the business model that has
been quoted so often and of course this
is politically charged we know that this
is one of Russia Zoo next five
priorities is to stop small boats from
crossing the channel here in northern
France and going over uh to Britain so
when we sat down with this man we would
identify him we uh we promised to
maintain his confidentiality there was
so much that we wanted to know and what
I found extraordinary was that he gave
us answers
we are meeting someone who earned his
money by smuggling people across the
English Channel his insights are
extraordinary the one thing telling me
British police need to start looking
much closer to home
we've obscured his identity and his
voice
is
foreign
[Music]
the French are not doing enough to stop
these Crossings but The Smuggler told us
that in fact it was getting harder
foreign
[Music]
and this is what he's talking about ever
more people setting off in small
overloaded boats heading across the
channel
the Prime Minister says it's a major
priority to stop these Crossings to
thwart the people Smugglers
would it make a difference if people
were sent to Rwanda when they arrived as
the government as the British government
has threatened to do this
would that change the business model
Amazon
foreign
on the beach the remains of a failed
crossing the boat's engine broke down
the passengers fled and the police have
now slashed the stingy so it can't be
used again we do see a sign of Greater
cooperation between the UK and France
but there are none of the promised
British offices on view here
for the French and British governments
this is the result of organized crime
Brazen illegality but the Smugglers
don't see it that way
foreign
boats like this one by breaking the
model of people smuggling he is
determined to succeed but so are the
Smugglers who send ever more people
across the channel and at the moment
they do seem to be winning
Adam the big question is how is this
going to differ from what we heard
previously from the likes of the then
Home Secretary pretty Patel you know she
said that she's going to stop these
small boats more than 45 000 people came
yeah lots of Home secretaries have said
they're going to tackle this the
difference this time is the government
says that it is going to effectively
stop people who arrive illegally from
claiming Asylum or to fast-track
deportations to Rwanda or to other safe
third countries but there are Myriad
problems with that number one is that
under international law it's not illegal
to come to Britain and claim Asylum so
there is a disconnect between what the
British government is saying and what
things like the U.N convention on
refugees are saying that's why Charities
who represent refugees are saying that
this demonizes people a second thing is
that frankly even if you bring this
legislation in it will take a long time
and it will be subject to an enormous
amount no doubt of judicial review it
sounds like strong rhetoric the question
is can it really be put into practice
great question and one that will be uh
posed I'm sure throughout the course of
the day for now Adam thanks very much
indeed Adam live in Dunkirk there now
it's reported this morning that Boris
Johnson has requested a Knighthood for
his dad and his resignation honors list
that as we expect the woman whose report
brought down the former PM that's Sue
gray to formally request permission to
work for the leader of the opposition
only in British politics tomorrow
standing by for us this morning what on
Earth is going on tomorrow well claimed
in the times this morning that Boris
Johnson's father Stanley well-known
former MEP and well-known figure in
Westminster has been nominated for a
Knighthood this is in the former prime
minister's resignation honors list it
hasn't been published yet but the times
say that this is what they understand is
in it now of course if that proves to be
the case Boris Johnson's brother Joe
Johnson a former minister is already in
the house of laws it's going to ignite a
row about cronyism and it'll probably
also ignite a route about a propriety
because of course a conservative MP
Caroline notes has accused Stanley
Johnson of touching her in a
appropriately it's also claimed in a
biography of Mr Johnson that Stanley
broke the jaw of his first wife
Charlotte Boris Johnson's late mother so
there's sure to be some discussion about
that a spokesperson for Boris Johnson
told me this morning they don't comment
on honors and it will be some months
before that list is expected to come out
but certainly that would be a
controversial appointment of so and Sue
gray I mean you could say that she's the
woman that brought down the Prime
Minister others might say it's his own
actions that brought him down but
certainly the report didn't help she's
now looking to work for the leader of
the opposition that's right she has quit
her job handling her notice at the
cabinet office and is preparing to work
for secure star but has been offered a
job as his chief of staff now we
understand this morning Sue gray is
going to be writing to the committee
that vets all of these applications from
ministers and Senior civil servants
looking to work in the outside world and
that committee which is called akober
the advisory committee on business
appointments will recommend to the Prime
Minister probably a length of time she
has to wait before taking it up it could
be months it could even be a couple of
years now in that letter she will have
to say what the timeline is of her
contact with kirst armor now we know
that his previous Chief of Staff left in
November is that when they began talking
I understand it's not expected to be
longer than a few weeks but she will
have to set that out because many Tory
MPS are saying we need to know when she
was speaking to him of course her
reporting to parties in number 10 came
out last May and you'll remember that
Boris Johnson was very pleased with it
at the time and believed that he'd been
Vindicated okay for now tomorrow thanks
very much indeed so what do you think
about Stanley Johnson potentially
getting a Knighthood you can let us know
if you would like to you can tweet me
directly at Cape early we've just been
hearing about some of his antecedents
um is it appropriate or is it nepotism
let us know your thoughts tweet me
directly if you would like to at Cape
early other news Charles Bronson has a
reputation as one of Britain's most
violent prisoners but he faces a public
parole hearing this morning that could
give him his freedom Bronson has spent
nearly 50 years in jail after his
original seven-year sentence was
extended many times because of his
violent attacks on prison staff and
fellow inmates in 1999 he held an art
teacher hostage for two days in whole
prison although he didn't physically
hurt him his victim was left so
traumatized he never went back to work
I've never learned anyone I'll Ever
Write to anyone
what am I in child for
you know he has an incredible violent
streak and it's very very risky to
release people like that and also then
what happens if he is released you know
the monitoring all the uh you know he's
going to be on a life license we know
that
um but it's a very a very dangerous man
who could be released into society you
know very shortly
after almost 50 years behind bars he
told our crime correspondent Martin
brunt in a postcard that it was his
mother's dream to see him free and happy
still to come on the program for you
this morning we'll speak to A Refugee
Rights charity about the government's
new plans to tackle illegal immigration
and after eight I'll be joined by the
shadow Health and Social care secretary
West Street
just before nine I'm going to be joined
by the British Adventurer who's broken
eight World Records while rowing in the
waters off Antarctica five months after
undergoing open heart surgery
foreign
news for you today figures exclusively
shown to Sky News show the economic
potential of women who want to work
extra hours but can't because of child
care costs and availability the former
head of the UK's vaccine task forces
claim that Matt Hancock acted like a
headless chicken during the pandemic
writing in the telegraph Dr Clive dicks
said the former Health secretary was
difficult to work with because he didn't
take the time to understand anything the
newspaper has published a tranche of
WhatsApp messages which a spokesperson
for Mr Hancock said showed a partial
account that was entirely wrong
fresh protest broke out in Greece
yesterday after last week's deadly train
accident the station Master accused of
causing the crash has been charged with
negligent homicide while the Prime
Minister has apologized for any
responsibility the Greek government May
Bear for the accident in which 57 people
died
thousands have been left homeless after
a fire at a rohingya refugee camp in
southeast Bangladesh it happened at
Cox's Bazaar which is home to over a
million refugees police have not said
how many homes had been destroyed but
said the fire was now under control
Ukrainian forces are under severe
pressure in the eastern city of backwood
but the founder of Russian mercenary
Force the Wagner group has warned his
troops are being deprived of ammunition
and could be forced to retreat he said
this could cause the entire Russian
front to collapse
now to what could be the most
humiliating result in Manchester
United's history you have to go all the
way back to December 1931 for the last
time the Old Trafford Club were beaten
seven nil and that was against wolves
but this defeat came against Arch Rivals
Liverpool at anfield and before the game
Liverpool Legend Graham sunes was
laughed at for suggesting his team would
win look look for the reactions at the
end of this clip
fully expect them to turn on today and
it's a long time Kelly since I've been
as confident about a Liverpool win
against United as I am today I just feel
it's going to turn up to I think it'll
be bang on it today you ask these two
chaps here is it easy to play here if
you're a United player this is a
difficult place for United to come and I
think the crowd will play a part today
as well
afterwards Salah tweeted an
extraordinary day for all Liverpool fans
I'm honored to keep making history with
this great Club
here's how to this is great two Club
Legends reacted as those goals were
scored former Liverpool Captain Jamie
carragher and ex-united player Gary
Neville it's fair to say they showed
contrasting emotions
let's have a look shall we
okay I think he's got a chance he's
gonna go
Rich Harvey Elliott here
headed in by Darwin Nunez
Manchester United apart here it breaks
for Salah
who dispatches with figure by Henderson
and another one for Nunez
it's five here
so it was two goals to his name two
headers Darwin Nunez
also departs
it's six
oh that's the one they wanted that is
the cherry on the icing on the cake
Bobby dazzler Bobby firmino
Le right let's bring in uh the science
Innovation and uh technology secretary
Michelle Donald is joining us um hello
Ms Donald just checking that you're not
a Manchester United fan this morning
good morning no I'm not okay okay good
for that are you a Liverpool fan
uh no no no
um I support my local teams but my
husband is very much a leads supporter
oh dear I'm so sorry
um
talk to me about small boats uh pretty
Patel promised to tackle small boats in
last year's nationality and borders Bill
and yet we had a record 45 000 people
more Crossing uh the channel
um how is what uh Rishi sunak is
proposing going to be different
I think you've hit the nail and had
those figures are staggering when you
compare where they were a few years ago
they were in their hundreds and it's
important that government does tackle
this it's why the Prime Minister made it
one of his top five priorities it's why
we've already taken action we've got
that record agreement with the French
government last year but that's not
enough that's why we're bringing forward
legislation the details will be
published this week and the basic
principle will be that if you travel
here illegally then it's not okay to
stay which I think is common sense and
the right approach
it's not illegal though is it to seek
Asylum it's illegal to smuggle people
into the UK shouldn't the Smugglers be
the ones that you're going for
I think it's got to be a proportionate
and uh of course we want to tackle
criminal ground gangs that's why we've
acted specifically to do that but we do
have to say it is not okay to travel
here illegally especially as we know
many of those people are traveling
across many safe countries to get here
in the first place and if they're
traveling here illegally they shouldn't
be allowed to stay we cannot take
everybody as much as we would love to we
just cannot and we have to have a system
that works and that's why we're bringing
forward this legislation is why the
Prime Minister has acted as I said we've
got that record deal with France we've
done a deal with Albania we've also
invested in more people to help us
process and get through the immigration
backlog in addition we're getting people
out of expensive hotels this is a
government that recognizes this is
something that people care deeply about
and is acting to address it but again
Minister it's not illegal to seek Asylum
it's illegal to smuggle people we were
speaking to a small I'm not sure if
you've seen our exclusive report he
tells us that most of the Smugglers are
based here in the UK what can we do
about it
but what we can do is bring forward the
legislation which is exactly what we are
doing
um I don't think it's right for people
to travel across many safe countries to
to get here and then choose to try and
uh seek Asylum via illegal roots that
that simply cannot be acceptable why
we're bringing forward this legislation
it's not illegal but as I'm saying it is
people travel it is people trying to
secure Asylum via a legal means by
making Asylum it's not
a legal minister
across the channel that's what's illegal
so what we're saying okay is that there
are safe routes to get into this country
that is the correct process not to
travel here on small boats across the
channel after you've gone through many
safe countries and we do know that a lot
of the people on those boats are
actually economic migrants not genuine
Asylum cases and as a country we have to
have robust processes in place to deal
with that that's why this prime minister
has made it a priority is why we're
coming forward with legislation on top
of all the other things that we've done
on this agenda so that we can deliver
and make good on that pledge to the
British public
most of those that seek Asylum at least
two-thirds are allowed to stay in this
country anyway because they do receive
their status here in the United Kingdom
so what is it that we actually what is
it that you actually want to happen in
order are you saying that we should
change the rules so less than 66 can
stay
I think we've been quite clear that the
principle of the bill is if you travel
here via those means you will not be
allowed to stay now the details about
yeah 66 coming out over the coming days
and yet 66 the details will be coming
out in the coming days
well yeah it won't be that 66 because
logic dictates if we're saying that if
you you come here via those means you
can't stay then 66 of them won't be able
to stay because we're changing that
we're saying that's not okay okay as I
said pretty Patel did say that last year
and that didn't change much but let's
see what what's in the detail in the in
the coming days let me move on to sue
gray lots to talk to you about Sue gray
next potentially the next new chief of
staff for secure what questions do you
have about her appointment
well I think it's it's less about what I
have as questions and more about how the
process was followed there will be uh
people looking into this room the
cabinet office side and of course uh her
appointment would have to go through a
cobra which is the correct means for
them to assess uh the next stage in her
career having followed her Civil Service
career whether it was done throughout
the correct processes and whether she
can take up that new office so we need
to wait to find out some of those
details that come forward
but you acknowledge that she was
politically impartial when she did the
um party gate report
well she was a leading civil servant who
um obviously swore and took to accepted
that the civil service code in which one
of those key requirements is
impartiality
and so you think that she was impartial
I think that that was not the question
here the question is
new job offer coming back I think she
was impossible
I have no reason to believe she wasn't
gay she was a civil service a service
servant who signed up to the the civil
service code I think what people are
mainly concerned about here is what
process has taken place for her to
acquire this new job have talks taking
place when potentially um they shouldn't
have Etc these are the questions that
need to be looked at and answered and a
cobra need to be allowed to do their job
and review this okay but she was
impartial when she did the report
um what about the former prime minister
nominating his dad for a Knighthood
that's surely nepotism is its finest
isn't it
okay I think that's speculation at this
stage obviously we've seen a report in
the media today but that's as much as we
know so who knows whether that's true or
not would you support it
wouldn't really be down to me um I don't
sign off those uh those those
appointments and those uh honorary
positions of course Prime Ministers and
previous Prime Ministers can then
nominate people for peerages for
different types of categories of honors
I understand and we have that system in
place which has worked successfully for
years but you'd be happy for him to be a
knight would you sorry okay I missed
that last question yeah I just said
would you be happy for to be a knight of
the realm
well let's wait and see before we start
speculating on ifs and maybe say okay
talk to me about the reason that you
joined us today
um growing the economy via Tech and
science how's that going to work
yeah so again the Prime Minister has
made uh many of his keyfight priorities
based on the economy cutting inflation
getting down the debt and uh growing the
economy which is fundamentally important
to improving people's lives getting them
better paid jobs and how do we do that
we do that by the true engines of growth
science and technology to spur on
Innovation what we've done today is
outline a strategic framework of how we
get there by 2030 that roadmap if you
like with action plans tagged onto it
but also we're acting in the here and
now too we've attributed 370 million
pounds to new initiatives including in
things like AI including in things like
money for Tech challenges so that we can
push through new technology and be at
the Forefront creating those better paid
jobs for British people here in the UK
okay it's great to talk to you um as
always look forward to seeing you in the
studio soon thanks very much
thank you kay
looking at the papers for you this
morning the mail says people arriving in
small boats could be deported and face a
lifetime ban from the UK that's what the
daily mail is saying this morning the
times also leading on government plans
to deal with irregular migration
The Daily Express says success in
stopping migrant Crossings could prove
to be an election winner for the Tories
the guardian has human rights groups
saying the plan is unworkable the eye
reports the Prime Minister and
Chancellor will rule out cutting
corporation tax in this month's budget
and the telegraph continues it's leaking
of Matt Hancock's messages they claim he
rejected advice to cut the 14-day covid
quarantine period
large parts of Scotland and Northeast
England are waking up to severe weather
warnings for ice and snow this morning
with temperatures expected to drop still
further let's get more should we our
meteorologist Steph standing by for us
hi Steph is going to be what the coldest
day of the year this week
it's going to be the coldest blast of
the year yeah that's true okay I guess
you were enjoying seeing the longer days
and the daffodils but nobody told the
weather we were supposed to be heading
towards Spring now and we've gone back
to deepest darkest winter they were
already seeing that very cold air over
parts of Scotland it's now heading into
parts of Northern Ireland as well so the
Met Office have issued a weather warning
we've got one for Monday and for Tuesday
it's a strange sort of shape really but
it just shows where we're exposed to the
Northerly wind because that will bring
us our snow showers we could see just
two to five over the lower levels but
over the higher ground over the two days
we could see up to 20 centimeters of
snow and you can see that snow just
edging a little bit further down there
as we head through the day on Tuesday so
for the South today it's actually going
to be relatively mild we're looking at
around seven or eight but that cold air
is already in the north and it's
gradually going to sink its way
southwards and as it does so as we see
those showers fall they could turn icy
as we head through the night as well
and have a look at this snows hurtle
down and mountain in Utah in the U.S
but it was well planned just look at all
of that white powder during an avalanche
mitigation operation it meant drivers
around Utah's Cottonwood Canyons were
stuck due to the snow
wow I won't be on the receiving end of
that would you and with parts of the
world experiencing extreme weather
conditions let's have a look at the
impact of climate change on the planet
here we go right half of the screen
using a little bit of coal today a lot
of gas uh of just over a fifth of
Renewables top left hand side is how the
temperature has increased since
1881.27 almost degrees and here the
millions of tons in CO2 emissions via
the University of Oxford uh coming up in
just a few moments time we're going to
be talking Toblerone and cheese
[Music]
it's over wrong
uh the Swiss chocolate maker Toblerone
we'll have to remove the image as part
of its production moving to Slovakia and
under Swiss law products can only use
National icons if they're almost
entirely made within the country and in
another blow for the Swiss a court in
the US has ruled that the name gruyere
can be used to label cheeses from
outside of the gruyere region of
Switzerland and France in a victory for
American Dairy groups the court said
gruyere can legally be used to describe
cheese regardless of where it is made
that's a lot of great to be said wasn't
it this morning on a Monday morning uh
still ahead a fluffy Survivor is pulled
from the rubble after a Russian strike
in Ukraine more on that
[Music]
hello again everybody now let's bring
you a happy ending from Ukraine where a
cat has been found alive after a Russian
strike on a residential building here we
go
this is a black kitten called Lisa she
was reunited with her owner by the
Ukrainian State emergency services in
the city of zaporizia despite the
destruction and piles of debris being
left in the wake of that Russian
shelling Lisa was miraculously unhurt
it's got to be a line there about one of
her Nine Lives isn't it
anyway a short while ago I spoke to the
science and Innovation and Technology
secretary Michelle Donald and I put to
her why the government is planning to
ban anyone crossing the channel from
ever claiming Asylum when acclaiming
asylum in itself is not illegal
I don't think it's right for people to
travel across many saved countries to to
get here and then choose to try and seek
Asylum via illegal roots that simply
cannot be accepted what are we bringing
forward this legislation it's not
illegal but as I'm saying it is people
travel it is people trying to secure
Asylum via illegal means Asylum
it's not illegal minister
across the channel that's what's illegal
so what we're saying Kay is that there
are safe routes to get into this country
that is the correct process not to
travel here on small boats across the
channel after you've gone through many
safe countries and we do know that a lot
of the people on those boats are
actually economic migrants not genuine
Asylum cases and as a country we have to
have robust processes in place to deal
with that
well let's uh bring in uh Beth Gardner
Smith CEO of safe passage UK hello it's
good to see you thanks for joining us
this morning what did you make of what
the minister was saying well I I think
she didn't really realize that seeking
Asylum anywhere in the world and in the
UK as well isn't actually illegal as you
said as you rightly said
um and this is what the vast majority of
the people who are traveling across on
these small boats are coming here to do
and we know that because it's borne out
by the facts
um that the government has recently
published you know the countries that
people are coming from are countries
like Afghanistan Syria Sudan Eritrea
these are countries that we know very
well are countries where people fear
persecution a fleeing conflict and to
give you an example last year just 22
Afghans were resettled to this country
you know the government talks about safe
routes being the alternative to people
but in practice they don't exist yeah
but then you've also got um young
Albanian men who fancy a better life
here in the UK okay and they're
expecting the British taxpayer to pay
for them it's true there has been a
significant increase in the number of
people coming from Albania but actually
if you look again at the statistics you
know over half of people coming from
Albania do actually receive protection
in this country and they do so because
they're fleeing persecution in their
home country they're often victims of
modern slavery and trafficking and so
what the government needs to do is to
actually you know assess people's Asylum
claims rather than um these you know I'm
afraid political gimmicks and you know
actually take the time to assess who who
has a valid Asylum claim and and and and
take a decision to allow them to get on
and rebuild their lives if they're
coming from some of these countries
they're passing through lots of other
countries before they get to the United
Kingdom they see us as an easy charge
they are but I I don't think that's true
at all and and and in fact you know in
France twice as many people applied for
Asylum last year in Germany three times
as many so actually it's a minority of
people who are who are taking these
dangerous Journeys to come to the UK and
why is that it's because you know I'll
give you an example we work with
unaccompanied children in northern
France in Calais and who are getting on
these boats at the moment
two years ago they were able to come to
the UK safely through a safe route
um that was family reunion that was part
of the EU system but unfortunately the
government chose not to continue on with
that safe route for those children when
they were able to we were able to get
them paperwork to come to reunite with
family on a Eurostar and you know in a
safe and orderly way now those same
children have no legal option in many
cases to come here to reunite with
family and therefore they're getting
onto these small boats risking their
lives and ending up in hotels across the
country they don't have to do that they
can stop at the first safe country and
that's not the United Kingdom if you're
an unaccompanied child or you know
another company it's not but these are
the cases that we deal with we also deal
with Afghans who are fleeing persecution
who served with our British armed forces
and they have no Safe Way talk about the
albanians who are particularly coming
when they don't need well actually we're
talking about everybody because this
government's plan
um is suggesting that we're going to
deny we're going going to ban the right
to Asylum for anybody coming on these
boats and that's many nationalities
Afghans albanians eritreans Sudanese
people who are vulnerable and we should
be taking a you know showing the
standard internationally by assessing
their Asylum claims quickly offering
them protection if they need it and
letting them rebuild their lives but the
British government is doing the British
people's bidding and a lot of British
people do not want Asylum Seekers to
find themselves on British Shores and
we've seen the outbreaks of violence in
hotels where Asylum Seekers are being
held which is awful but actually I think
if you look across the country at what
people and communities have done for
Ukrainian refugees that tells us a very
different story about the comparison
between Ukraine and Albania I think you
can make the comparison between you can
talk about the British Public's attitude
towards refugees and if you look at what
we've done for ukrainians opened our
communities opened our homes to them you
know I think most people across the
country believe that if you're fleeing
war in persecution you should get a fair
hearing and you shouldn't be detained in
Mass detention centers as this
government is proposing indefinitely for
the rest of your life so how that we're
at an on-pass at the moment the
governments say they're going to bring
in stricter laws and we're going to hear
the details from as early as tomorrow
what are you most concerned about that
the Prime Minister might say well I
think this ban on people claiming Asylum
coming across the channel is the most
serious and also the absence of any plan
to offer safe alternatives to people
that's what we really need to see from
this government now isn't that what
Rwanda would be though people would be
able to find themselves in a safe place
in Rwanda why do you object to that well
Rwanda is not a safe country for very
many people as the courts have rightly
said you know they've they've prevented
individuals from being deported there
because they're worried about people's
safety and in fact that plan would only
um you know if it if it ever got up and
running would only Deport
um you know a few hundred people a year
so you know we're not really talking
about practical alternative solutions
that are you know moral Solutions as
well and and unfortunately what the
government's proposals suggest is that
we're going to see people detained tens
of thousands of people detain
potentially right across the country
um indefinitely men women and children
has been suggested by this government
without giving them an opportunity to
rebuild their lives and with no Prospect
of sending them to another country which
we should you know because in many cases
they're fleeing war and persecution so
you just think anybody wants to come
should be able to come that's absolutely
not true no but we need safe ways for
those who have Asylum claims that should
be heard and who have family here and
Community ties to be able to come here
and get a fair hearing and that's our
responsibility as a country we many
countries across the world take in
refugees in fact the UK has a small it
takes in a small number every year and
we should be doing our bit just as we've
done with ukrainians and to to help
those who are fleeing more in
persecution seek a better and to be able
to rebuild them and those who aren't
should be repatriated
those those who who don't have an asylum
claim here should have a fair hearing
and if the decision goes against them
you know they that's that's the decision
that's the point of an asylum system but
at the moment we don't have an asylum
system that's working we have over 160
000 claims that are waiting for a
decision that's what the government
needs to be focusing on getting a grip
on the Asylum backlog and sorting out
the system so people aren't stuck in
hotels people are able to get a fair
hearing have a decision on their claim
and if it's positive rebuild their lives
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
very much and if you're doing this much
appreciate it uh time now for a look
through
um some of the photos that have caught
our eye today and it's over to India
where yesterday's Hindus celebrated the
holy Festival
oh it's very colorful isn't it Hindu
devotees crowded around a modified 1921
Rolls-Royce car carrying an idol of
dirty Krishna through Heritage Landmark
Harbor Bridge in Kolkata these little
girls were photographed trying to put
paint on
on each other as is the custom during
the festival how lovely
joyful innocence of Youth now the fire
brigades Union is awaiting the outcome
of a ballot on a new payoffer a strike
by firefighters was put on hold while
union members consider the revised offer
if the action had gone ahead it would
have been the first uk-wide fire strikes
in more than two decades joined Now by
The General Secretary of the fire
brigades Union Matt rat hi Matt it's
good to see you again how are you so
thank you will you be going on strike or
not
it looks like we won't be
um we get the results of our ballots uh
this afternoon at two o'clock it's
counted by an independent scrutineer so
we don't know the full outcome but all
the indications we've got are that our
members are likely to accept stats
revised pay off us so we look like we
will have avoided a strike in the fire
service so tell us what you were offered
and then what you were what the revision
was so we our pay is due our pay rise is
due on the first of July each year and
in June last year we were offered a two
percent rise which was very rapidly
rejected and we began a campaign and by
then inflation had obviously
significantly taken off and we then got
a revised offer of five percent in
October last year which we put to a
ballot of our members and our members
voted by 79 to reject that and we then
moved to a stripe ballot and our members
again voted overwhelmingly for a strike
if necessary we had a an Emergency
meeting with our Employers in February
and they came with a revised offer which
was for seven percent for 2022 and a
second year offer of five percent for
2023 uh plus a few
um discussions around issues that we've
got concerns about and we considered
that the exact our executive then
recommended that and that's out for
consultation so our members have an
individual vote on that as I say that
vote will be counted and finalized this
afternoon at two o'clock it's less than
other public sector workers some other
public sector workers will be receiving
why why do you think it's acceptable
it's well it's more than many have and
we we have disputes in many parts of the
public sector I think it shows the
advantage of being able to sit across
the table with your employers and
negotiate we don't have a pay review
body for example we don't want to pay
review body I think they're they seem
pretty widely discredited in the eyes of
uh hundreds of thousands of workers
covered by them and certainly we're not
sugar coating this for year one or 2022
it will it will be below inflation
although better than was originally
offered for year two 2023 it's uh if
predictions are correct then it would be
slightly above inflation for that year
you don't know yet they're doing and see
what inflation is doing
um soon if the government's legislates
accordingly you won't be able to go on
strike well uh that's it's an outrageous
attack as far as we're concerned clearly
we didn't nobody wants to strike strike
is a difficult thing for any group of
workers to do particularly workers in
the fire and rescue service but it was
clearly one of the factors that improved
the dialogue with our employers and I
think this is an attempt to reduce the
bargaining power of ordinary working
people simply as a way of forcing their
wages down and it seems to us completely
undemocratic should blue light workers
be able to go on strike you're going to
say yes of course but I mean the police
are not allowed to are they well the
police are in a very different position
their rights were attacked in 1919 we
are not police officers we're civilian
workers we work for local authorities
the same as uh people who who don't they
no they work for they're employed by the
chief Constable they have a different
legal position and firefighters our
members are civilian employees they have
the right to join trade unions as they
do across most of the world and we want
to be treated the site in the same way
as other other civilian workers so we'll
know it two o'clock this afternoon no at
two o'clock this afternoon we appreciate
you taking the time to join us thank you
as always thank you now let's move on to
other news for you this is an
interesting story Tennessee has become
the first U.S state to ban public drag
performances in public spaces other
states are proposing similar legislation
why let's get some reaction in just a
moment or two from Jamie Campbell you
will recognize Jamie
um he actually watch him in this and
then I'll tell you more
so talk to me about what's going on in
in the US and the fact that they want to
ban
um drag performances in public what's
that
um it's absolutely ludicrous
um I think because so basically in
Tennessee they have now brought in a law
and that bans
um adult performances and adult
entertainment and Mr Hall and the groups
drag into that
um and drug is just such a massive
spectrum of things
um and yes there are adult drag
performances of course they are in
nightclubs
um but then there are drugs may or may
not have seen some yes I'm sure you have
um but then yeah this drug that is is
suitable for children I mean we've had
pantomime which is amazing oh yes we
have and that is um yeah a big massive
part of it so I don't get what this law
is trying to do apart from just stir up
anger and hate and just open up this as
a way to attack the community and how do
you think the community will respond to
that I mean like everything the
community we've been through so much
over the years and so I don't imagine
we'll take it lightly
um but at the end of the day a drag is
just
a spectrum at the end of the day and
it's just like policing art it's where
is the line here I think that is the
problem like the law is so vague
um
and yeah like what we just span dresses
in general or like makeup or having fun
um and that's just all drag is really
and right next or whatever exactly just
before pride month as well yeah so
government uh Governor Lee
um there's an image he's a republican
you'd be surprised to hear
um and from his high school years
apparently showing the future Governor
dressed in drag himself yeah that is it
um he's wearing like a pearl necklace
and a cheerleader outfit and when
questioned on this um Governor Lee has
said oh no but that's different you
can't compare this
um so he's basically saying it's okay
for him as a straight man and just to
dress like this um but there's a
difference when other people do it
how to say good
oh um and just join us for pride month
ensure that drag is fun and yeah just uh
That what girl would you be
concerned that when stuff like that
happens in the United States it could
spread to other states very quickly and
and perhaps casting an eye over the
Atlantic to us and well that's it it's
um poisonous it just starts somewhere
and then it goes out and out and out and
I think at the end of the day things
like this are
put out there to distract us from the
real issues like gun violence for
instance in America that is just the
real culprit and the real danger because
at the moment I'm sat here talking about
this with you and other people are over
there
um yeah it's just a distraction
technique yeah I mean I said
um Governor Lee if he was sat here he
would uh say that the Bill's only
stopping children from seeing sexualized
acts
um and that that is appropriate well I
mean at the end of the day a drug is not
always sexual and most the time but
we've agreed that it can be I mean it
can be but I know me as a performer as
well I do shows at pride month and for
children and we tailor our act for that
like we wouldn't be performing a really
provocative routine for children
um and yeah like I keep saying it's a
spectrum and
yeah I agree um children shouldn't
necessarily be exposed to explicit
explicit content
um
I did my first drag performance at 16.
um and I remember seeing my first ever
drug performance when I was maybe eight
years old in Lanzarote
um and
um since we had a video tape but all of
that um performance and looking back on
it when I was older like yeah there was
maybe
um sexual things in that routine but as
a child I didn't notice that I just saw
the the glitter the cams the makeup the
feathers and I loved it and I think
that's the thing with children
um they don't focus on
the undertones and things like that like
in pantomime for instance even like
there's a lot of sexual undertones in
the jokes and stuff but it just goes
over Children's Hospital audiences it is
it's for all audiences and what are you
doing now
um I am writing a book
um I'm staging my drag come back funnily
enough which is going to be coming out
um during pride month as well
um and I've got my fingers in lots of
little pies
um but um so yeah will you talk to us um
Jeremy
um of course yeah and I might wear
something a little bit more theatrical I
was just going to say I mean could you
maybe be a little bit more lively next
time you're here okay
it's lovely to see you too thank you my
darling thanks a lot for coming in a
quick look at his birthday it is today
none other than the basketball big man's
birthday here he is Shaquille O'neal He
is apparent he's 51 and apparently he is
seven foot one inch tall which is only
slightly taller than me huh I don't know
why you're laughing that behind the
camera we'll see at the top of the hour
thank you